do you believe jesus christ wants to heal you
yes okay what i am going to do
is I going to pray
you can just relax
so keep your hands like this
make sure that his millimeters are slightly apart
that you are not tense
so I'm going to pray
the power of god is going to come and they are going to grow straight
in jesus name
I command your arms to grow straight
right now in the name of lord jesus christ
that's the power of god
what do you feel happening
listens this woman says
where were you in pain
and where is that pain now
i don't feel it
you had pain in your shoulders
you also had pain in your shoulders
come in jesus name
you are totally cured
right now
the pain is gone